in our previous video we discussed the
paralysis questline talking about rogue
ai and what they can do to the people in
night city eventually an in-depth video
on mr buize will be talked about to
fully close that story and get the other
side of the questline as while it gets
relevant for that video there's a lot to
catalog with him and his organizations
or i think he deserves his own video but
in the meantime i wanted to talk about
another personal favorite quest of mine
that deals with religion
faith and corporate exploitation that
would be the center man questline with
joshua stevenson for the basics to start
this quest we must complete the hellman
retrieval quest once completed sometime
later we'll receive a call from wakako
she mentions she has a client who is in
need of a merc for a kill job the client
is willing to pay large amounts of
eddies to make sure everything goes
right he wants us to kill someone and he
wants to tag along to see for himself
after waiting we meet the client bill
jablonski we're then told to wait until
the car when josh arrives then we tail
them
while inside we ask bill some more
questions to understand why he wants him
dead
bill says that josh murdered his wife
and was put on death row but for some
odd reason he is now out of jail and not
going to get death sentence
bill believes this is unfair so we're
gonna be the new administers of his
death sentence so to speak according to
bill he is being transported by some
ordinary corporal people so there
shouldn't be too much resistance
in the middle of our talk we do see the
vehicle and chase them down it's not a
long or tough chase although a couple
cars do get in the way and apparently
josh harnessed the power of the sun to
distract me and make me crash but
overall wasn't too bad a little later
they pull over and we're presented with
two options should we succeed and shoot
on site bill will die and we have to
take on the cop named vazquez by
ourselves as well as any law enforcement
that shows up due to us shooting a cop
after his death we are free to shoot the
lady in the front and josh in the back
or blow up the vehicle killing them both
we then receive 5 000 eddies and we end
the quest line
alternatively the more preferred option
is not to attack when exiting the car we
can hear bill
talking about killing him the job was
originally for us to be the hitman but
now he wants to take the lead he is then
shot by vasquez almost immediately josh
gets out and protects us telling vasquez
that if he shoots our deal is off
the lady in the front gets out and
disagrees asking to have us killed her
name is
rachel without even knowing our name
josh begs us to join him we can
constantly ask him why he wants us to
come along and what for
but we get no answers only saying that
we will find out on the way there
johnny finally arrives and is
surprisingly excited about the situation
that's it got no [ __ ] idea what this
is about
but if you don't go with them i'm never
talking to you again
if we leave the area and don't enter the
vehicle we fail the quest and they take
off without
us if we do hop in we get to talk with
josh moore josh 12 years ago was
sentenced due to armed robbery and
murder as he states himself he had a gun
and didn't like the way the people
looked at him so we shot them behind
bars he had lots of alone time and in
that alone time he found peace through
god
once again we can ask him why the hell
we're even still here and he says that
if we join him for the rest of the day
the studio will pay us the roughly the
same amount that we get if we were going
to kill him i guess this studio is in
some way related to rachel as she
doesn't look like a cop and definitely
the odd one out in this car this while a
small piece is still a piece of the
puzzle regardless so we press
on assuming we said no when asked to be
pulled over we leave the vehicle and in
the quest line this is one of the many
instances in this quest that we can just
up and leave whenever we want to we
arrive at the house and a woman named
zuleka answers the door
they seem to know each other could
possibly be a relative or a friend of
his that he wants to visit before they
head to the studio
osha josh and dulaka sit down have a
prayer and talk
hopefully we'll finally be able to get
some answers
zuleka is the sister of the man i killed
ha
listening more it seems like zuleika was
sending letters to josh while in jail
and they reunited through forgiveness
going a bit back we obviously have a ton
of questions when asked why she would
let him off the hook like that she
responds with a bible verse specifically
luke 6 37
do not judge and you will not be judged
do not condemn and you will not be
condemned
forgive and you will be forgiven this is
going to be one of the many times this
happens throughout the video so i'm
going to mention this now as a person
who isn't very well versed in any type
of religious text or prayers it's
obviously going to be hard for me to
understand some of the verses and their
possible true meanings i'll do my best
to explain the significance of the
verses as good as i can when they appear
throughout the questline but to anyone
who is more well-versed in certain
religious texts than i am i encourage
you to comment and give your thoughts on
these as i think it'd be creating an
interesting dialogue for this verse
however zuleka talks about judging
forgiveness and condemnation
and says that she shouldn't judge a
person on their actions as god is the
only one that can see their true
intentions inside them this verse talks
about the plague of humans and that is
the spirit of judgment while this verse
is important in the current context the
prefix is just as important as it talks
about the gospel of luke something that
will be a little bit more relevant later
in the questline the second option talks
about josh's redemption
and zubika will alternatively say that
she lost one brother but god gave her
another josh further explains that it
was zuleika's letter that started it all
so she shimbu found god herself which in
turn made josh find it as well thanks to
her letter we could tell zuleika that's
great but didn't your god have your
brother killed
she says that she grieved for days over
her brother's death but god showed her
his plan and she found peace
josh says that he does regret killing
ruben and god knows he does we can also
point out how devoted they are as people
of religious faith which is quite rare
in night city
she says that it was god's interaction
with our world that brought us here to
our home
josh will then ask us what our beliefs
are if we say we're unsure and that we
kind of need proof to see
suleika will say that the only person
who can prove god's existence
is us if we don't believe in a higher
power then he simply just doesn't exist
in our life and vice versa
saying we do or don't believe will lead
to the following dispute from asking
either one of them we uncover the real
truth the media found out that josh
discovered god in prison and they wanted
to capitalize on it and have him record
some brain dances this brain dance would
be him getting crucified so they could
clearly disagree saying that they are
just using him but josh explains how he
was going to die anyway thanks to his
death sentence but now he's been given a
platform to help spread a message to the
world about god and his faith we can ask
more questions like the reason for our
brain dance and why not something else
josh then says he was transformed into a
child of god by zuleka and he wants to
repay his debt to her saying that he
wants to show his true unconditional
love and that if love exists then so
does
god and that everyone can feel his
warmth and should be reminded of his
divine existence
he wants to reach everyone joy toys
corpos gangs
everybody he wants them all to bear
witness to his message of god we can
address our distaste for all of this or
ask the law's opinion on all of this
and he brings up that he has a one-day
supervised furlough so he is allowed to
visit people
during this time after this choice
zuleika's mother will walk in she's
already well aware of josh and says that
josh and us are not welcome here
josh tries to apologize for his actions
but is shouted at and called a murderer
i wanted to fully exhaust this dialogue
before i mention this but
i'm assuming that weird thought may
still be in your mind that even though
she has found peace through god and
accepted the loss of her brother why
does she talk to josh like he's a casual
friend i was originally going to say
it's stockholm
syndrome which is when a person who is
captured sympathizes with their captor
except zuleika is clearly not captured
the sympathy part exists from the
syndrome just not the captured part
it's up in the air really would you want
to believe what's going on with her you
could say it's really deeply rooted
trauma being hidden by herself as she
tries to find answers to the
unanswerable question of
why did this happen or maybe it is god's
way of helping her and not some facade
either way it's evidence she's clearly
doing better which is something to
celebrate regardless of how it happened
we can leave and continue the quest but
let's explore the residence the family
house is surrounded by garbage and they
live under a highway
i can't imagine the amount of people who
live above or even the people on the
highway that just chuck garbage down
onto their house
upon entering the house we see a
memorial for reuben with a holy bible
and some candles on it there's really
nothing else downstairs besides this
although we can try to talk to zuleka
and her mom but we get no response
upstairs is two rooms which have some
shards and a computer with messages
outside the two rooms is some
medications it's hard to read the label
but this is either some simple
prescriptions for someone in the
household or medications due to the
trauma of reuben's death considering
there's a lot of bottles it could be the
latter the far door opens into a simple
looking room but has a shard called
your god your kiroshi this is about the
many religious practices and their
stances on body modification
for a brief summary it seems the
catholic church isn't opposed to
implants and some clergy men have
implants as well so it may even be
accepted in the religion mormon faith is
quite different as they don't accept it
saying no god fearing mormon can support
implants whether it's for functional or
aesthetic purposes the only exceptions
are life-supporting or health-related so
a pacemaker or something like that would
be okay for islamic faith most muslim
leaders speak out against it but it's
not officially prohibited and then
lastly for judaism they don't provide
any implants for their members except in
the hasidic communities where they are
regulated by their community leader this
is interesting as it seems that
religious communities give out implants
or at least provide implants to its
members
and the other room is a computer and
another shard this shard is titled the
coptic bible it has an excerpt from the
book of enoch from section 1 chapter 6
and section 1 chapter 7. some may also
call this the book of watchers as this
encompasses the first 36 chapters
chapter 6 talks about the watchers these
are angels who were sent to earth to
watch over but eventually lusted over
the women of earth they wanted to have
children of their own and be able to
choose their wives so they searched for
future partners
chapter 7 talks about the watchers again
and how they became so infatuated with
women that they taught them their spells
and enchantments
the woman would then become pregnant and
give birth to giants that were thousands
of feet tall who devoured mankind
including birds fish
beasts and even themselves i'm not the
slightest clue how this relates in the
context of the game this could just be
something zuleko was reading or maybe
it's a favorite section of the book of
enoch honestly i have no idea so if you
have anything definitely let me know
on the computer we see four messages the
first message is to a reverend nassau
talking about her brother's death and
how to follow in christ's path the
second message is a thank you to
reverend nassau who apparently visited
the family at their house
the third message talks about the sign
of jonah and how she hopes that one day
she'll be able to leave the belly of the
beast and see the light the fourth and
final message is a thank you to reverend
nassau
this is how zuleka was able to heal from
the tragedy thanks to reverend nassau
and his talks of love and forgiveness
this is most likely what prompted zuleka
to write the letter and send it to josh
and of course we know the rest with the
house fully covered we can head back
inside the car we then stop by a nearby
diner for a bite to eat and josh has
some small talk with us and is still
very insistent on getting
crucified before we get out and going to
the diner however rachel wants to talk
with us
all options will lead to the same
dialogue choice in some way but she
thinks that josh is crazy and definitely
would benefit from psychiatric help
but they need josh as he has
authenticity too many bds these days try
to sell a story but these actors are
faking the emotions and it doesn't feel
real but with josh what he feels is
authentic which is something that is in
short supply but an
insanely high demand in the
entertainment industry the reason she
called this over is because we are
making him question himself too many
probing questions as she says it can
make him doubt himself and not perform
as well she offers us a deal
leave now and get double what we were
offered if we leave and end the quest
johnny gets upset at us and we get paid
in a couple days
even if we try to walk back inside the
quest does not continue and rachel tells
us to buzz off but we're already too
deep into this story so we have to press
on
johnny talks to us before we head inside
and he discusses his thoughts on the
whole situation he thinks it'll end in
pain and profit and is interested to see
how this resolves
when we sit down we're then presented
with two options of dialogue so let's
discuss the bd first
the bd is called passion and you may see
its image art posted around night city
quite a lot they're planning on speaking
to the lowest common denominator of
people and hopefully revolutionizing the
bd markets
josh only has one day because of his
furlough so there isn't much time to
make a whole bd so they're just going to
be using the last part for actors in
movie magic so to speak to get the rest
of it finished this is where we come
back to the gospel of luke as rachel
states that josh forced the writers to
go with luke's ideals and not john's
like they originally wanted
josh thinks that jon's version is crude
and over the top and that luke speaks to
him more
the studio clearly agreed as it would
help with the authenticity rachel stops
us in the middle of our talk as she
wants josh to not be distracted
we also have two options here but let's
go back to that previous option as this
one's also going to end up back here
anyway the other dialogue choice in the
beginning is changing the subject v
is sick of discussing faith constantly
and wants a change of pace and wants
josh to choose he's never been given the
floor to speak freely like this so he is
a little flustered but he discusses with
us about the remake of badlands raid
we say whatever option we prefer is it
all ends back to where we left off
rachel's been nagging us all day so we
could tell her to [ __ ] off
joshua and i are talking
excuse me realize the stakes here
tomorrow this guy's gonna create his
masterwork
i would like to rest now
perfect
that wasn't exactly how i thought this
was going to go but it's an option
nonetheless
she says that we'll still get our money
and we're told to leave instead of that
we can ask her what she does to relax
josh agrees as he knows nothing about
her we find out she frequently uses
meditation to relax
both options will lead us to her being
displeased with us and ask us why we're
even here in the first place
she once again cuts us off at both our
options saying that she doesn't care
what we have to say and that all this
talk about grace and salvation is making
her puke
she then gets up and leaves we say our
goodbyes to josh and he goes too
johnny appears and talks with us more he
agrees that josh definitely has a few
loose screws but this is all still
corporate exploitation we can give our
thoughts on it ranging from feeling
sorry to not caring about him at this
point we could just get up and leave or
we could ask johnny on his thoughts
about the afterlife and the existence of
a higher power he explains that he died
and came back so there could be some
meaning to it but johnny assures us that
it's completely false and it was just a
clever bit of corporate technology not
some miracle
v questions if the afterlife exists and
that if johnny is already there and
we're just talking to his digital
epitaph johnny doesn't care and probably
never will
he's just living with what he's got and
he's just gonna go along with it now
that all the dialogue has been exhausted
we can leave and head home
until sometime later we get a call from
rachel josh is having a nervous
breakdown and says that he needs us to
calm him down
we make our way to the studio and see an
angry mob outside judging from the signs
and chants
these are religious believers who
disagree with the actions that are about
to take place
we walk past them and we meet with
vasquez who instructs us where to go
before that however is a shard on the
table this is one of those shards that
exists in the playable area of a quest
or mission
but don't really pertain in any way just
some cool general lore just from the
point of view of a brain dance addict
and just talking about their life
experience with it besides that there
really isn't anything outside the studio
besides two people arguing out back so
we head inside there's a lot to take in
here so let's talk about the scenery
first it's your typical studio with lots
of production equipment camera crew and
scaffolding with the main centerpiece
being the giant cross in the middle of
the studio
there are a lot of shards in here
however and a laptop the laptop only has
one message talking about the production
nothing really of note except it's from
rachel talking to someone about how the
writers are taking too long at least we
aren't the only one she's annoyed at as
for the shards one is called he found
jesus in prison
this is of course talking about josh it
says that josh over anything wants
forgiveness for what he did it goes on
to talk about his crimes like assault
and murder it seems to be a discussion
about the whole situation in general as
this person is giving their opinions on
is saying this could just be a way for
him to get on parole and not get the
death sentence
the next shard talks about the warsaw
catholic faith and its origin
this is more of an informational shard
to provide the reader with some
interesting information on specific
fates and values
we can find this shard in other places
in the game as well this could possibly
be here because someone from the studio
is reading into more religious face now
another part of the crew for this film
or maybe to possibly understand things
being said during the film or maybe
they're just curious another is called
mystical rapture and film
the first couple lines tell us about the
decline of the supernatural in films
maybe this is another reason why the
crew jumped on this when they discovered
josh not only is he authentic but the
subject matter of this bd is low in
supply so it's not an oversaturated
market from a marketing standpoint this
is quite smart for the studio our next
shard is glam now apparently some woman
has been an advocate for bd
diets she apparently goes into the bd
hungry and then comes out like she ate a
full meal
since she feels full after using the bd
she doesn't need to eat and because
she's eating less calories she's getting
skinnier there really isn't any proof to
this other than just her word but it's
quite the thought-provoking article the
last part talks about
carrie of all people and how his nudes
were leaked online but were confirmed
fake because his iconic tattoos were not
in the photo and that according to him
his dick was not the correct size
thanks to the detail carrie our last two
shards are in the room with josh the
first one is a body count lottery
according to this the final number was
going to be 2 14
until a corner store murder happened
that killed mrs jablonski and mr el
hamar
of course this was josh's murder seems
like both our grieving parties had their
loved ones killed at the same time at
the corner store but then there's also
the obvious body count lottery
apparently death is so common in the
city that they make bets on how many
people will die
quite the dystopian society the last one
is an excerpt from the book assassinates
specifically chapter 9.
chapter 9 is more of a conjunction of
the book's major themes of death and the
value of wisdom
josh was most likely reading this in an
attempt to calm down from his mental
breakdown when we talk to josh he asked
us to join him in prayer with him there
are technically six
options so it starts slow the first
option is to let josh pray by himself
while we sit there next to him for moral
support he says the prayers of saint
augustine to the holy spirit this is not
about praying to god
for what we need from him but instead
praying to increase our desire
for god so that we may receive his
future blessings if we decide not to
pray then he prays to himself and we
just wait
our last option is that we lead the
prayer we have four options to choose
from the first is the lord's prayer one
of the more well-known prayers this is a
prayer obviously recognizing god and all
he does for us and that he continues to
watch over us in all our endeavors the
second option is a fragment from the ami
da
this is a hebrew prayer that is usually
said while standing so a little off that
we're
sitting while doing this but the prayer
is about constantly reminding the
individual of god's existence and the
daily act of repentance
our third choice is from the rig veda
used in hinduism the themes of this
prayer are similar to our past two
verses
and the last one is a prayer of our own
this seems just to be a very popular
prayer of good fortune
after this moment of prayer we are
presented with the last three options of
the game
josh not only wants us to be there for
him while he's crucified but also nail
him to the cross for the easiest option
we can just say we don't want a single
part of it and our only objective is to
leave once that's done we go on our way
and continue the game we can opt to do a
bit of both in terms of the extreme
options where we say we'll join him but
will not nail him to the cross
the last option is going through with
the whole plan we walk with josh as he
sets up on the cross while saying a
prayer we nail both his arms and feet to
the cross
johnny appears and bows his head in
respect the only thing left to do is
wait until josh dies and it's an
uncomfortably long time
nailing him to the cross was hard to
watch but just watching him as he sits
there losing blood is also uncomfortable
too
regardless of your choice this ends the
quest we get our xp and we can leave
a little bit later we will receive a
call from rachel either talking about
the success or the failure of the
braindance the difference between the
two
is how much money you receive and if
rachel's mad at you this is determined
by dialogue throughout the whole
questline our dialogue has been secretly
being tracked
in the background and certain dialogue
choices give us a number this number
determines the outcome of the bd hitting
a 4
5 or 6 is considered a failure and a 0 1
2 or
3 is a success these dialogue options
are as follows
at zuleka's house if we say yep still
not buying it or
whoa insane that's what this is we
receive a point for each
in the car ride if we use our cool stat
and talk about where we want to eat that
is also a point
inside the restaurant if we ask to stop
talking about faith that is
also one point and our last one is worth
two points which is at the studio we
receive these points if we say this is
crazy don't do it or
you got pure intentions but this isn't
the way to act on them when josh talks
to us for the first time
but notice the running themes for most
of them it's what rachel talked to us
about in the beginning
asking probing questions because we said
all these to josh he didn't perform at
his best and the bd failed to garner a
larger audience
the points are tied to the probing
questions that make josh think about his
decision and after hitting 4 of course
walt's not shown his mind was most
likely clouded with our questions and he
wasn't paying attention and didn't
perform well while being filmed
sadly no matter what happens in the end
a very running theme for this game in
general we really don't get a happy
ending
josh will die regardless and be
crucified but at least we can make the
bd a failure to get back at them for
exploiting him
this was an interesting quest not only
did it bring religion into question it
did so in an interesting way
josh and rachel are also some
interesting characters in terms of their
intentions and ideals as you can either
think josh has really found god or he's
just mentally insane
then with rachel who's a corporal trying
to exploit josh a clearly not mentally
sane person for profit it's a quest that
had me thinking about it a while after i
finished it then definitely one of my
favorites in cyberpunk 2077 but this
though
ends the video and i want to thank you
all for watching hopefully you enjoyed
the deep dive of the quest center man
if you want me to do more of these
videos leave me some recommendations of
quests that you like down in the
comments below and i'll consider looking
at them but with that like the be if you
do enjoy subscribe if you're new
take care everyone and i'll see you in a
future video
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you